let's hear from a few more people we do
our calls via discord you can join the
discord for free at davidpakman.com
slash discord
let's go
uh let's go next to ben from texas ben
you're on the air
ben from texas you're on the air
and ben from texas there you are you
hear me yes i can
all right um just to the callers they're
asking
uh what joe biden can do um if we don't
win the midterms for abortion
i was thinking along the lines can joe
biden do something to the effect of
withholding federal aid to states that
limit abortions past the three months or
before three months
you know that's a that's a great
question it's an empirical question that
i just don't have the answer to in front
of me could he withhold federal you're
just saying like stop all federal aid to
states that ban abortion before three
months
well not all federal aid something that
doesn't really affect the everyday lives
of people but can definitely hit the
wallets of the of the states of the
state governments like see the tough
thing about that is even if let's assume
that he could do it
it probably will hurt the people of the
states regardless i think that that's a
reality i don't know how you would hold
money from states and say we're going to
withhold the money but it's not going to
do anything bad to anybody well that
seems unlikely
right and then um like i'm from texas
i'm where this
six month abortion ban has already taken
place i work six months or six weeks or
six months or six a week oh six weeks
i'm sorry got it i'm a social worker
i've seen the effects that are
draconian
sexual education
has had on
on uh people
you know
our lack you know our foster care is
just in absolute shambles there's it's
overwhelmed underfunded
this is just it's insane to me that that
we're
limiting women's access to health care
right now do you think about leaving the
state of texas over what's going on
uh personally i have reasons that i
cannot but if i didn't have those
personal connections here in texas i
would definitely be looking to leave
gotcha well i mean that's the most
people have connections where they live
that's kind of the reality that's why
this whole if you don't like it just
move thing is is very absurd
yeah and then just one other thing just
uh i don't know if how much y'all talked
about it but uh myra flores um the
there's a runoff election going on down
here
um because our congressman um
uh philemon vela is taking an early
retirement to be a uh to be a lobbyist
and
this is an area this is a district i
live in south texas um the rio grande
valley this area has been
a strong blue for about 40 years
and right now it's looking like the
republicans are going to be taking over
this this congressional district yeah
so
uh i mean if we if we can get the word
out that
this
this uh candidate might have floyd she
is
she makes she's she's another uh lauren
bulbert kind of deal oh boy i have not
been following that one i have not been
following that one but we will look into
it
yeah she's she's definitely a threat to
look out for
all right ben from texas thank you for
the very informative call
thank you david all right been on a
slight delay there with us i don't know
what was the cause of that i don't know
the oranges of that